welcome back so where we left off in the
last video i had shown you this thing
called the geometric series and you know
we could have some base a it could be
any number it could be you know
it could be one half it could be 10 but
that's just what some number and we keep
taking it to increasing exponents and we
sum them up and this is called a
geometric series
and so
i want to figure out the sum of
a geometric series for you know when i
have some base a and i go up to some
number a to the n
why did this a to the
what did i write a to n minus two there
that should be a a to the big n oh yeah
i
my brain must have been malfunctioning
in in the previous video that always
happens when i start running out of time
but anyway
let's go back to this so i defined s as
this geometric sum
now i'm going to define another sum and
that sum is i'm going to define as a
times s
a
times
s and that equals well that's just going
to be a times this exact sum right
so
and that's the same a is this a right
that a is the same as this a so what's a
times this whole thing
well it's the a times a to the 0 is let
me let me write it down for you so this
will be a because i just distribute the
a right a times a to the 0 plus
a
times a to the 1 plus a times a squared
plus all the way a times a to the n
minus 1
plus
a times
a to the n right i just took an a and i
distributed it along this whole
this whole sum
but what is this equal to
well this is equal to a times a to the
zero that's a one a to the first power
plus
a squared
a cubed plus bub
a to the n right because this is you
just add the exponents a to the n plus a
to the n plus one so this is
a s
and we saw before that s is just the
original sum
that is just
a to the zero
plus a to the one plus a squared plus up
up up up all the way
to plus
a to the n right
so let me ask you a question
what happens if i subtract this from
that
what happens
if i go if i say
a s
minus s
well i subtracted this from here
on the left hand side what happens on
the right hand side
well all of these become negative right
let me do it in a bold color this
becomes because i'm subtracting negative
negative these are all negatives
negative negative
well
a to the first minus a the first that
crosses out a squared minus a squared
crosses out a to the third it'll all
cross out even all the way up to a to
the n right
so what are we left with we're just left
with
minus
a to the zero right we're just left with
that term
and we're just left with that term plus
a
to the n plus one and of course what's a
to the zero that's just one
so we have
a to the s
i've done it is a times s
minus s
is equal to
a to the n plus one
minus one
and now let's distribute the s out so we
get
s times a minus one is equal to a to the
n plus one
minus one
right
and then what do we get well we can just
divide both sides by a minus one let me
erase some of this
stuff on top
erase
i think i can safely
all of this really
well i don't want to erase that much
i want to erase this stuff
that's good enough
okay
so i have
just
dividing both sides of this equation by
a to the a
a minus 1 i get s
is equal to a to the n
plus one
minus one
over
a
minus one
so
where did that get us
well we define the geometric series s as
equal to the sum
from k is equal to 0 to n
of a to the k and now we've just derived
a formula for what that sum ends up
being
equals a to the n plus 1
minus 1
over
a
minus 1.
and why is this useful well
we now know if i were to say well what
is
what is let me let me clean up all of
this as well
let me clean up all of this so we can
okay
so if i said
you figure out the sum of
i don't know the powers of
three up to three to the
i don't know three to the
tenth power so
you know three
so three to the zero plus three to the
one plus three squared plus all the way
to 3 to the 10th so this is the same
thing as the sum
of k equals 0 to n
of 3 sorry to 10
of 3 to the k
right so this formula we just figured
out a is 3
and n is 10. so this sum is just going
to be equal to
to the 11th power
minus 1
over
3 minus 1
which equals
well i don't know what 3 to the 11th
power is minus 1 over 2.
so that's kind of useful that's that is
a number um although you'd have to
memorize your exponent tables to the
11th power to do that but i think you
get the idea this is especially useful
if we were dealing with well for if the
base was a power of 10 it would be very
very easy
but what i actually want to do now is i
want to take
this and say well what happens if n goes
to infinity let me show you
so what happens so there's two types of
series that we can take that's not what
i wanted to do
there are two types of series that we
can take that we can find the sums of
there's finite series and infinite
series
and in order for an infant infinite
series to uh to come up to a sum that's
not infinity there they need to what we
say they need to converge and if you
think about what has to happen for them
to converge is every
next digit has to essentially get
smaller and smaller and smaller as we go
towards infinity so let's say that a is
a is i don't know let's say it's a
fraction a is one half so what how does
the geometric series look like if we
have one half there so let's say that
we're taking the geometric series
from k is equal to 0 to infinity
so this is neat we're going to take a
infinite sum an infinite number of terms
and let's see if we can actually get an
actual
number oh you know we take an infinite
things added up and it actually
adds up to a finite thing this has
always amazed me and the base now is
going to be one-half
it's one half and it's going to be one
half to the k power so this is going to
be what one half to the zero plus one
half plus what's one half squared plus
one fourth
plus 1 8
plus 1 16. so as you see each term is
getting a lot lot smaller right it's
getting half of the the previous term
so what what happens well let's say what
happens if this wasn't infinity what
happens if this was
n
well then we would get plus 1 over 2 to
the n right 1 half to the n is the same
thing as 1 over 2 to the n
and if we looked at the formula we
figured out well we would say well that
that is just equal to
one half
to the n plus 1
minus 1
over
1 half
minus 1.
and and that would be our answer we
would have to know what what n is but
now we want to know what happens as we
go to infinity
so this is essentially a limit problem
what happens what's the limit
as n goes to infinity
of one half to the n plus one minus one
over one half minus one
well all of these are constant terms so
nothing happens so what happens is this
term right here goes to infinity what's
one half to the infinity power
well that's just that's a that's zero
that's an unbelievably small number take
one half to arbitrarily large exponents
this just goes to zero
and so what are we left with we're just
left with this equals minus one
over
one half minus one or we could
multiply the top and the bottom by
negative one and we get one over one
minus one half
which equals
one over one half which is equal to two
i find that amazing if i add zero plus
one half plus one fourth plus one eighth
plus one sixteenth and i never stop i go
to infinity and not infinity but i go to
one over you know essentially two to the
infinity
i end up with this neat and clean number
two and this might be a little project
for you to actually draw it out and just
like maybe a pie and see what happens
you keep adding
smaller and smaller pieces to the pie
but it never ceases to amaze me that i
added an infinite number of terms right
this was infinity and i got a finite
number
i got a finite number anyway ran out of
time see you soon